must be a hundred 150 feet must be big
round table six chairs right there room
for more everybody breaking news we have
to talk about the Batman movie in the
fact that Ben Affleck will not be Batman
during it now that doesn't mean that
he's never going to be Batman again in
any other DC movie it just means that
he's not going to be Matt Reeves Batman
so we'll break it down but if there was
any doubt Ben Affleck confirmed the news
by retweeting the article will do a new
round of the Amazon giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite Batman moment on
the video the reason why we're getting
this news is because Matt Reeves is
doing press for some other projects and
he did this big spread on his Batman
movie talking about his take so it just
means that Warner Brothers is finally
doing some publicity for the movie we'd
heard about it for so long there were so
many rumors mainly the talk was whether
or not Ben Affleck was gonna be in it
because it was supposed to be sort of a
younger version of the character early
in his career this way if Matt Reeves
described it he did a much longer
preview so I'll break that down in a
second he talked about the rogues
gallery the villains he was going to
include and how it was gonna feel
different from the other Batman movies
that we've seen so far but the actual
news release just reads Warner Brothers
dating their next rendition of Batman
for June 25th 2021 so that's when the
movie is coming out meaning that they'll
be casting their new Batman before the
end of the year but the article goes on
to say Reeves boarded Batman February
2017 taking over for Affleck who was
originally set to direct off a script
that he wrote with Geoff Johns remember
their version of the movie was gonna
have Deathstroke be the main villain
that was what that whole costume test
was for a couple years ago so I'd even
think about it you're gonna be playing a
Deathstroke in the new Batman which is a
bad guy yeah you to an extent to an
extent I mean you know that the
character of Deathstroke is very
specific
you know there's he's but I mean the
building of that character is very
similar it was gonna be their version of
raid redemption with Batman fighting his
way through his rogues gallery of
villains down Arkham Asylum level by
level
part of the reason why they're not doing
that version of the script is because I
think it was part of Matt Reeves deal
when he came on he's like if I'm gonna
do Batman I want to do my own script so
Matt Reeves is not only the director of
Batman he's also a producer and the
writer so when you hear people talking
about this version of the Batman movie
it's like holy on him that's one of the
reasons why it's gonna feel so different
from other Batman movies and one of the
reasons why I think that Ben Affleck
chose to pass the torch so to speak the
article isn't too harsh on Ben Affleck
it does say that he has a lot of other
projects that he's producing because Ben
Affleck is a director and an actor and a
writer so he has a lot of his own
projects that he likes to work on the
way the article writes him out though it
says Affleck worked hard on the Batman
story talking about his original version
of the script but knew he wasn't the
right one for this particular version
the one that Matt Reeves is gonna be
doing so a search is underway for a new
Dark Knight like I said if they're gonna
be releasing that movie summer 2021 and
that means they have to start shooting
by early 2020 so that's why I will
probably get some news release in
December right before Christmas or
something like that a surprise everybody
this is gonna be your new young version
of Batman really important detail though
Ben Affleck still has two movies on his
Batman contract with the studio in the
Matt Reeves movie is gonna be a prequel
of sorts set very early in his career as
Batman so you're talking
twenty-something Batman
so just because Ben Affleck is not gonna
be in that prequel movie doesn't mean
that he's never going to play the Batman
character again or not cameo in any of
the other present-day movies but right
now there are only a couple of other
opportunities for him to do that there
the Harley Quinn birds-of-prey movie
that's happening that's kind of a Batman
spin-off because they're gonna be set in
Gotham so it's totally possible huge
cameo and that we all wondered if he was
gonna show up in the flash movie when it
was still gonna be a flashpoint movie
because Batman is a big part of that
story but now because that movie has
been delayed it sounds like the story is
gonna change a little bit and it'll be a
little more self-contained because
flashpoint is a big Justice League
crossover story the Suicide Squad sequel
the James gun is writing right now they
haven't confirmed him to direct he's
just writing the script is called the
Suicide Squad returns they just
confirmed the release date for that
movie is August 2021 Ben Affleck could
also cameo during that so right now
there are three movies that he could
look
show up in let me know in the comments
where you want to see him next in
present-day movies everybody has a lot
of ideas about who they want this new
younger version of Batman to be so when
I say that he's a twenty-something
Batman that means that they could cast
any actor in their 30s or any actors
that looks like they're in their 20s and
could still look young by the time they
finish a trilogy of Matt Reeves Batman
movies so they haven't said anything
about Mary's doing a trilogy but you
have to assume that if his Batman movie
is successful that they'll want to make
sequels to that that will be set during
that timeline and it'll still have to be
that young version of the character so
right now you're talking about people
like armie hammer Jamie Dornan Ryan
Gosling Ben Barnes people who are
younger but they don't have to be really
really young actors Matt Reeves recently
gave a big preview in an article of his
movie this is me just reading his quotes
so he says it's very much a
point-of-view driven noir Batman tale
it's told squarely on his shoulders and
I hope it's going to be a story that
will be thrilling but also emotional
it's more Batman in his detective mode
than we've seen in the films the comics
have a history of that he's supposed to
be the world's greatest detective and
that's not necessarily been part of what
the movies have been so far I love this
to be one where we go on that journey of
tracking down the criminals in trying to
solve a crime it's going to allow his
character to have an arc so that he can
go through a transformation what he's
talking about there is is that mostly
Batman movies have turned into really
big action thrillers ever since the
Christopher Nolan films so Michael
Keaton Batman films were big action
films even though they were a little
more over the top then obviously they
became really campy when Joel Schumacher
came into the franchise then when
Christopher Nolan came on they really
turned into big blockbuster films not so
much noir detective thrillers so you
didn't get so much of the world's
greatest detective Batman you just got a
lot of big toys a lot of big explosions
in really crazy epic action scenes so it
sounds like Matt Reeves is trying to
bring him back to his comic book roots
without completely losing out on all
that really cool action like it still
will be a really big really awesome film
it'll just feel a lot more like classic
Batman in the comics the most recent
description that somebody who used to
work inside Warner Brothers gave me
about
at least early drafts of his script is
that it was basically Batman mask of the
phantasm that kind of a film with
slightly different characters so if you
never saw that film probably one of the
best Batman films of all time it just
happens to be animated it has Mark
Hamill's Joker in it Kevin Conroy Batman
it's sort of a reimagining of his origin
story and something that happened early
in his career with a person that he was
really close to that sort of defines
what he is going forward beyond just the
basic vengeance that you get after his
parents died and he vows to avenge them
someday like he goes way deeper than
that during mask of the phantasm the
place is wired to explode know one way
or another it ends tonight goodbye my
love
he says there's no official title but
there unofficially calling it the Batman
so for now that's just what we'll call
it he confirms there's gonna be a big
rogues gallery of Batman villains he
wouldn't respond to the penguin
questions because a lot of people are
like why is josh gad doing so much
penguin posting on social media is he
gonna for that role what's going on but
i think this is just matt reeves saying
that there's gonna be a number of
classic Batman villains but I do think
that the penguin is meant to be one of
the bigger ones they asked him about how
his movie is gonna feel with all the
other DC movies that are happening
because Aquaman is like the most amount
of movie you could put in a movie in the
history of movies it is the biggest
thing that they have done in a long time
it felt even bigger than Justice League
he just says that he's focusing on his
movie he's not really involved with
what's going on in Shazam or the Holly
Quinn movie or the Todd Phillips Joker
movie which itself is coming out later
this year we're probably due for a
trailer for that pretty soon but
remember that movie is also a prequel of
sorts - because it's the origin story of
The Joker whether or not you think we
need an origin story for the Joker
everybody says creatively it looks
really cool so we'll just see what it
looks like when we actually get a
trailer but during the course of that
movie Thomas Wayne is a young man so
either Bruce Wayne is a really little
kid or he has not been born yet he's got
a couple other projects that he's
working on so just expect people to
hound him about the status of the Batman
and who the new actors gonna be who the
villains are going to be for the rest of
this year hopefully they'll have an
official presentation to give
weren't at comic-con this summer and if
you're wondering whether or not this new
young version of Batman would ever be in
the present day films like if they would
just continue him on and whatever next
Justice League movie they wind up doing
it is possible but when Ben Affleck is
wishing them well like saying you know
good luck I can't wait to see this movie
it's gonna be awesome
he's not saying that he's never gonna be
Batman again so I think a lot of it just
depends on the scripts that come his way
and if he likes what he sees and he's
not all booked up on his own projects
then he will come back but if it doesn't
happen if he doesn't cameo in something
within the next couple of years
then the studio will probably just
release him from his contract but I know
everybody wants to see a live-action
Batman Beyond film and even though I
think that Ben Affleck could play a
great older version of Batman in that I
still think that Michael Keaton would be
the first person I would go to for a
Batman Beyond film just to bring the
franchise full circle back to Tim Burton
back in the 80s but let me know in the
comments what do you guys think about
this I'm sure you have a thousand
questions just post them in the comments
and I'll try to answer as many as
possible
there was another video that I was
actually working on while this news
dropped because Kevin Smith heard the
story of all stories about a secret
trilogy of Justice League films that
we're never gonna get to see so I'll do
a video for that in the next day or two
just because it's a really big story but
this huge Batman news just felt like it
was the bigger thing that I needed to
talk about first weight of the day for
DC news so while you wait for that
Justice League video click here for that
birds-of-prey trailer and click here for
my brand new spider-man far from home
sinister 6 trailer video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]